mark steelo's day job is engineering
cars like the brand-new supercharged
Camaro z28 for General Motors but he's
better known as the guy who literally
wrote the book on pro-touring the art of
restoring vintage vehicles with modern
power and handling look at the tire
maker birthday
best thing dude is that your job is like
your hobby and your hobby is looking job
when you're doing up at 69 Camaro to
make it exactly what you want today did
you take the same kind of approach when
you look at this Camaro
the 2014 z28 is the most track-ready
Camaro ever made unlike previous hypo
muscle cars this Camaros focuses on
handling and stance rather than
horsepower alone only the nameplate is a
throwback to the 60s era Camaro what are
the highlights the big highlight was you
know the ls7 engine is just a great
motor really tractable it's got that
nice free revving you know it sounds
awesome it works really well we really
went after cornering and braking and we
really need a really strong tire and a
really sorted chassis with a big Kia
neighborhood on this car and the z28
will come with a stick shift crew that
it was engineered by a true car guy not
a bean counter I'm a Camaro guy my first
job at GM was doing showroom stock
racing and kind of doing the last
extreme performance bearing on the
fifth-generation camaro kind of a nice
little Astrakhan history book for me I
think about when I was a kid reading the
motor trend car driver all with
different magazine articles about the 69
z/28 and now I'm writing that history
this has been a dream come true this is
exactly what I wanted to do